The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aihi
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim at a house in Jenna. And we
know the great reward that will not only
be gained but rather will fill your
grave after your death. Whenever someone
prays there, whenever someone gives
shahada in the masid, whenever someone
learns something in the masid, yes, that
will be something that you'll have on
your scale.
[Music]
How are you guys doing? We haven't seen
Ali Dawa for a while, but we've got
someone else. Someone
someone who we started the channel with
actually uh 10 years ago. We we done the
first videos on this channel, this
notorious and prominent channel,
Muhammad Hijab channel, the best channel
on YouTube. Me and you made uh the
videos together.
>> You remember that? How was that?
>> Must have been the best days of your
life. Really?
Then you went and done other things.
You got nothing to say about that.
Well, now this is your debut. Okay. No,
no, no.
>> The pro debut. The amateur debut was uh
was before 10 years old.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> This is the pro debut. Um, this is the
pro debut. Um,
and we're going to be getting straight
into it with something that we both
we've already spoken about it actually.
We've done a video and um about
feminism, okay? Something we both don't
like, frankly, if you want to put it
that way, and what it's done to our
communities and and what it's not to say
we don't like feminists and people who
associate with that kind of thing. We
there's a distinction we make, isn't
there?
>> It's damaging. It's damaging. I think we
see the damage that it can bring to
society that it can bring to families
that it can bring to social
>> constructs
>> and that's that's the reason we don't
like it like you said it's not in the
individual it's in the ideology
>> some people who classify themselves as
feminists who have no qualms with them
as people in fact some of the very nice
people very compassionate respectful
>> uh people um but we came across this
video of Candace Owens
>> who has actually been in the good books
of the Muslim community recently because
of her stance in Palestine she's been
very gallant and very respectable. Uh
and in fact to be fair like she she has
taken very principled stances against
the Daily Wire. Um she was dismissed by
them and most people say that it's
because that she she took those stances
against Palestine. So we have a lot of
respect from that perspective. But um I
recently saw cuz I was on the Jubilee
channel with all these kind of uh people
around one person.
>> Mhm.
>> And she was debating all these feminists
and we both watched the video. Uh we
wanted to maybe react to a couple of
segments from within it so we can speak
uh about these very pertinent uh
poignant issues. So maybe let's hear the
first uh thing and then come back and
respond in kind. life are more fulfilled
when they achieve a family unit and when
they have children, women in particular
especially having aspiring to children
then you are going to end up with a
bunch of people who are unhappy because
your job cannot replace the feeling of
having a family. So what you're saying
is we need to look at every individual
case and see what is going to fulfill
you or what is going to I guess
essentially predict your happiness more
because if we look at for example the
Nordic countries right these are
countries I'm talking about like Sweden
Denmark right these countries tend to be
like I think in the past 14 years
they've been ranked as the highest in
happiness and marital satisfaction from
women right and we see that they also
have been the most open regards to like
you know sexual norms and and you know
sexual roles right so and we also see
that there's less rates of like STDs
reported. Um we see um
>> yeah so we've seen the back and forth
there and then Candace does make after
this she makes a few points about
suicide rates etc. But I think what
should have been mentioned by Candace
here to be honest are the main studies
on um the declining female happiness.
So, one of the main studies that was um
recently relatively recently put out was
a study by Stevenson called the paradox
of declining female female happiness.
And in fact, it built upon the studies
of Blanch uh Walder and Oswald who had
this longitudinal study from the 1970s
up until 2000. And they went to um the
United States of America, they went to
England and they actually surveyed women
psychologically, right?
um and ask them if they feel better or
worse with their satisfaction in life
despite like conditions economically
being much better for them because
obviously this is after the civil rights
movement and after the second wave
introduction of second wave um ideas and
stuff like that like the gender wage gap
the um the abortion all these things
were enshrined into legislation now but
what they found was that women were
becoming less happy so despite them
being more in work more in in terms of
career and etc etc they're actually less
happy and a lot of the reason is because
of the burden, okay, of being at work,
having a double, being a mother, being
doing all these things at once. What do
you have to say about that, Ahmed? What
do you think of of of these um of these
findings?
>> Notice how it's never called the burden
of a career or the burden of work, but
it's always referred to as the burden of
childbirth or the burden of children. M
>> um like the the even the language which
is used is very deliberately chosen when
you're speaking about a career or work
or boss.
>> Yes.
>> Versus when you're speaking about
children or family or a husband.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> And I think that can't be ignored.
That's one
>> that that is a very good point. Yeah.
>> Two, I think I mean just going back to
the claim which is that
>> you will be more fulfilled if you have
children as a mother as a as a woman
>> you will feel more fulfilled. i.e. more
happy in life
>> if you have a family, if you have
children.
>> This is like I don't even understand why
this is this is a conversation.
>> Why is this a point of contention?
>> It's biology.
>> You are you are literally one of your
main functions as a human
>> is to reproduce.
>> It's one of the main almost you could
call it if you want to a purpose of
being a human being.
>> One of the main things that you can do
as a human is to reproduce.
>> And it's so important. It's it's an
urge, right? M
>> it's an urge to reproduce.
>> Both men and women have this urge.
>> Why are we attempting to sideline those
urges and those desires
>> and quite frankly needs?
>> Why are we attempted to sideline that
>> in the name of happiness when in reality
we know that it's not actually making
you more happy.
>> It's making you less happy actually.
>> Exactly. But then the moment you make a
claim like that,
>> you'll see just how defensive
a lot of the feminists they get.
>> That's true. they get incredibly
defensive and
>> what she said that the other woman that
was speaking to Candace by the way she's
very articulate and she was coherent so
to give her credit for that and she was
trying to make an argument however she
was mistaken in her argument right so
she was saying look at the Nordic
countries look like basically the
Scandinavian countries uh they have a
higher happiness rate etc etc but what
she's actually looking at is the
happiness index okay and even if you
look at the happiness index website if
you go on their website it's an economic
indicator it is not a psychological
indicator to the point where they
actually spell this out themselves. So
they admit that happiness index is not
um an actual measure of how happy or sad
people are. In fact, if you look at the
happiness index, you'll find that for
example, it includes things like human
development index, if it includes things
like GDP per capita, includes GDP,
includes like um life expectancy or
literacy rates, whatever it may be. But
the assumption is that if you have those
things in place, then you're more happy
and then they base the happy countries
on on the ones that have higher economic
v variables like that. But we know rich
people in the west despite having all
those things that we just mentioned
being in in in great conditions
comparative to the rest of the world or
other parts of the world are still not
happy because when you look at the for
example uh Forbes magazine done a done a
um a study with the WH the World Health
Organization and they found actually 19
out of 20 most depressed countries in
the world are actually western countries
and that's another layer of paradox
here. So you've got the paradox of
female happiness which is that they
expected when you give women all these
rights and you give then you let them go
out and work and whatever they'll be
more happy. actually they found the
opposite and you have the paradox of
capitalism because in a sense you expect
to give more people more money and then
be more happy and actually the opposite
is true and it's interesting because I
was speaking to Demsky um who wrote
dopamine nation actually and she had
written this in her book and we have
gone we I had spoken to her about this
in the podcast that she mentions it's
you know it's still the case in the west
you know that you have all these things
going on so it's not true what she's
saying is actually false it's and and
for her to connect it with um sexual
orientation.
>> I mean there is zero evidence that being
gay makes you happier than being there
is zero evidence. Okay. Um there is zero
evidence. In fact I'm sorry to say I'm
so sorry to say there's evidence to the
contrary. Yeah. There's evidence to the
contrary because if you look for example
I was I was speaking to another person
called uh Wilfinger and he had written
these books about I' done a you can find
the podcast he's written these books on
divorce and stuff like that and I asked
him he he's a demographer and he deals
with what are the structures of the
families that are most happy and he said
a nuclear family for example a a nuclear
family with mother and and he even said
a religious nuclear family
>> that they attend for example some kind
of worship once a or something like
that.
>> So don't pretend, okay, that two men or
two women are going to give you the same
happiness, the same quality of life, the
same satisfaction as a traditional
nuclear family because there's nothing
in sociology or psychology peer-reviewed
respectable that actually backs up your
claim. Aren't lesbians the most um
abusive of?
>> And she makes that case uh I think
Candace in somewhere there is good
evidence to show that in lesbian because
think about it
>> relationships. If you think about it,
bro, like when you when you've got a man
and a woman, you've got a power
imbalance.
>> Okay,
>> I'm sensing some flamboyant.
>> No, no, no. I mean, it's true. Maybe not
with some of the people watching this at
home. Some of the these guys, but but
you should have naturally a power
imbalance.
>> When you have siblings that are like
same kind of same strength, same size,
they fight each other all the time and
it's it's inconclusive.
>> But when you have one strong and one
much weaker, then it creates stability
that that dynamic. So when you have two
gays or two like men or two women, then
the abuse on both sides is likely to be
more.
>> It it makes more sense that way. Anyway,
>> but let's see the next uh next clip
because we want to get we can't go
through everything,
>> but before we do, there was just one
extra point I wanted to mention which is
um you mentioned
>> let let the woman work and and giving
the woman rights and what have you.
>> Um it's not only let I want to focus on
the letting the woman work part. It's
not just letting women work.
>> And by the way,
>> working letting her or not, you know,
her working. Yeah.
>> No, but it should also be mentioned like
the issue here is not, oh, we we don't
think women should work. That's not what
we're saying.
>> Yeah.
>> Because obviously we know a lot of these
a lot of these statements get can get
taken out of context very easily.
>> It's not just letting women work. It's
encouraging women to work. And not only
encouraging, but
>> as a substitute to being a mother.
>> Yeah. but also but also making it
incredibly disadvantageous to not work.
>> It's it's you put all of the especially
the financial stress and pressure and
strain on a family unit or household
like we see here in the UK for example
in London.
>> Look how expensive it is for to rent a
very very basic
>> quite shabby to be quite quite frank.
Quite a shabby home like a two-bedroom
flat.
>> Yeah. It's very expensive and if even if
you have a decent middle class job like
a teacher, you might be earning 2 and a
halfk a month
>> but your rent is 1 and a halfk
>> and on the bills
>> and on some gross before you know it
>> you're left with like £100200 a month
>> like is that really a way to live? So a
lot of people they find in order to
mitigate
>> that problem is to have two
>> a twoinome household which is obviously
now become the norm.
>> So it's not just letting women work or
encouraging women to work. It's making
it almost impossible for women not to
work. And I think that also needs to be
mentioned.
>> It is. And that's is is they're doing it
for finan economic reasons because they
want to tax
>> Yeah.
>> um half the population. It makes sense
from their perspective. But the thing
is, if you think about it from the other
perspective, when you don't have a
cohesive family and a woman looking
after children, uh traditionally, right,
a man and a woman, but like you have a
primary role of a woman mother doing it,
especially in the formative years. Yeah.
When you don't have that, then these
kids are more likely according to most
studies to come out to be criminal, to
come out to be degenerate, psychological
and pathological issues and so on and so
forth. And then that is taken back from
the economy because if they're criminals
and they go to prison, then they can't
give taxes. If they if they're sick,
mentally sick, then they can't be as
productive. If they're physically sick,
they come and so on and so forth. So
they think they're save they think
they're saving money from one
perspective, but they're losing it from
another. And the health of the society
is more important than how much money
ends up in the treasury in in the UK for
example or the US or any other country.
>> Let's see the next uh clip. Uh
>> okay. How many women have paid maternity
leave?
>> Okay. That's not
>> like how how are how are things panning
out in the family courts? Why are
abusive men having access to their
children? Like why are women making less
than men? Like what I mean none of that
means anything to me.
>> If I may.
>> Yeah, please. Yeah. Yeah. Of course. Of
course. this the terminology,
>> the use of the vocabulary, the word
abuse
>> and just what
>> can fall underneath that the umbrella
>> of the word abuse.
>> When we're saying abuse here, like uh
>> she was mentioning um uh how many
abusive parents have access to their
children. I'm going to get to the
children part in a second. When we
mention abuse, it's worth noting that in
the eyes of the law, abuse can mean very
very many things. M
>> very many things. Is that good English?
>> Yeah. Yeah, it's good. Very good.
>> I don't know why that sounded weird.
>> Yeah, it's still
>> many many things, right? It can mean
physical abuse.
>> Yeah.
>> It can mean mental abuse. It can mean
emotional abuse. And then what falls
underneath emotional abuse? Oh, he he
made me feel small.
>> He made me feel little. Why did he make
you feel little, Lily?
>> Oh, because uh he's 6'6 and uh handsome
and dashing.
>> 6'7, right?
>> 67. I wasn't
talking about you, brother.
>> 6'7, handsome, handsome and dashing.
>> Talk about the handsome. It has to be
me. What are
>> you talking about, brother?
>> So, um like it could be anything. Oh,
okay. Yeah. And he said uh
>> that the way I cut the cucumber was was
triangles and he doesn't like triangles
and I put a lot of effort into my into
that salad and he didn't appreciate my
efforts.
>> So, for that reason, I felt abused and
>> Yeah. I mean now now they have stretched
uh the meaning of that and do you know
what the sad thing about that whole
thing is?
>> The sad thing is that for people who
actually suffer from actual abuse
>> you know actual abuse that they are hurt
physically and it doesn't always have to
be physical. There are psychological
abuses.
>> Yeah. We're not saying there is no such
thing as psychological abuse. But when
it's genuine and then these other people
are just using the term around loosely
and making it lose currency. Kind of
like the word anti-semitism.
>> Yeah. 100%. When you overuse it, it's
like a current a currency. It becomes
>> overvalued or it becomes inflated.
>> It loses it value.
>> Yeah. It becomes inflated in value when
there's a lot of demand.
>> So when there's a lot of supply and not
enough demand,
>> it's the law of So when you keep using
something, you're it's like you're
supplying the economy with it. Oh,
abuse, abuse, abuse, abuse, abuse,
abuse. So abuse has just become one of
those things now. Yeah.
>> It's like anti-semitism or whatever.
Like if you attack Israel, it's just one
of those things now. So we people have
to be cautious in their use of that
because if they don't use this stuff
correctly from our paradigm perspective
we have Quran sunnah tell us what true
abuse is and what true abuse isn't as
Muslim people we know if you want to
know what abuse abuse is essentially
that's what oppression
>> and and for us to know what abuse is all
you got to do is say okay what does
Islam allow for example there are some
things Islam allows that some other
feminists and others would consider it
to be abusive
>> so the the idea of uh male authority,
male um men in in a household saying to
a woman do this and do that or whatever,
making a final judgment on issues that's
considered to be co coercive control or
abusive to some people, but in the
Islamic lens, it's not necessarily so
>> obviously not.
>> So yeah, so do you know what I mean?
Unless he tells us to do something which
is like, you know,
there's no obeying the creation, the
disobedience.
>> Exactly. Like you can't tell her like
prostrate to me. You know what I mean?
Like
>> you cannot there's no disobeying the
creation and the disobedience to the
creator as the prophet told us.
>> But the point I'm making is so this use
of the word abuse. But then I don't
think men should be singled out with
this because if you really think about
it bro like you tell me why shouldn't
they be singled out?
>> So so she mentioned how many abusive
fathers have access to their children.
Now there's something which needs to be
mentioned here.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Tell me. if he was abusive
to
>> the mother of the children and then
obviously the question comes what kind
of abuse does that mean would that
hinder his access to his children
because obviously there will be cases
>> there will be cases where that does make
sense
>> there will be cases where the father
>> uh should be uh
>> stop trying to kill the kill the woman
of course
>> or or something even less than that but
>> yes exactly there are many cases
>> but
>> if the issues of this abuse whatever
that may be are between him and her and
have nothing to do with the children,
then why on earth should the children be
punished? And we see this a lot.
>> We see this a lot,
>> especially if it's a subjective thing
where she thinks abuse and it's not
consensus definitions of abuse.
>> Exly. Oh my word. And you throw in is
there evidence? Is there evidence
enough? Uh throw in all of these things
into the works and before you know it,
you can claim anything to be abuse. You
can claim you can make lies and get away
with it and and say this happened
>> because it's almost like you're guilty
until proven innocent circumstances.
>> And then the worst thing about it is
>> how many so so she's mentioning the
abuse of the father
>> and then how he has access to the
children.
>> How many women have abused the father?
Not just the father abusing the the
mother. How many mothers have abused the
fathers by restricting their visitation
rights to the children? or we see this
very very often.
>> It's true. And they're abusing the kids
by doing that.
>> They are damaging the children. And this
is the worst thing like a lot of the
time that it's it's abuse. We're going
to put a whole bunch of things under the
umbrella of abuse. That's abuse. That's
real abuse. That's mental,
psychological,
>> uh the only thing it isn't is probably
physical to be honest with you.
>> But that's serious abuse on the
children. And whilst we claim that we
want the best for our children and we
love our children and
>> that's not what's best for them.
>> No,
>> that's not what's best for them. them
having a relationship with their father.
That's something which we know from the
evidence. Yeah. Which I'm sure you're
going to site now
>> in terms of single parent households and
just how more likely they are to enter
uh gang violence or or enter
>> like the boy crisis written by Farrell
for Warl Faren.
>> Yes.
>> Is that how you say his name? Yeah.
Warren Farrell or Warl Faren. One of the
two. But sometimes I get confused
between the two. But it's the the name
of the book is the boy crisis. this
where he he cites all these examples and
stuff of how basically a single parent
household
>> um has and especially a single parent
household with a woman by the way
>> he seems to indicate that if it's with a
man they have more success
>> yeah I saw evidence sorry to cut you I
saw
>> Warren Warren yeah Warren Farrell yeah
>> I saw evidence to suggest that children
that are raised in a joint household
mother and father
>> uh are
have high likelihood to be successful
>> children that are raised only solely by
their father have a high rate of being
successful. And children that are raised
solely by their mother don't have a high
rate.
>> Not not as high a rate of being
successful.
>> Doesn't mean that we can't have people
like me and you.
>> That's true. That's true. Of course, it
goes
>> exceptions of the rule here.
>> But that's exactly what it is, right?
Like there are rules and there are
exceptions to the rule and it's very
important that we don't we don't rewrite
the rule based on the exception.
>> That's true. like
>> but no this is a good point and um I I
think it's also worth noting okay that
according to many charities a lot of
like children char I think the NPCC
being one of them that actually abuse
that happens to children and of course
they have their own definitions of abuse
and that can be critiqued like anything
else academic but according to their
definition of abuse mothers are actually
way more uh frequently abusing their
children than fathers now that's not to
say um that they're worse than them or
anything like that mothers in many ways
are they put so much more sacrifice and
our religion tells us to put a lot of
respect on mothers and
you know your mother your mother your
mother and your father and all these
hadith where the prophet is indicating
that companionship should go to the
mother in fact
>> the the the institution of motherhood
the idea of motherhood you know the
vocation of motherhood all of that is so
much higher in Islam probably than any
other religion okay and it's mentioned
so many different time the Quran even
when it says
you
to both of your parents be good is
referencing a root eMMological word
which indicates the one who gave birth
to you which more suits the mother
really and in fact the Quran
specifically mentions the mother
and so on that she held him and it was
difficult for her she hated doing and
then She gave birth. So the Allah gives
credit in the Quran to mothers and Islam
very high stat very high status. And
this is one of the problems bro
>> you know feminism it really does demote
the institutionhood
>> big time. It's it's almost like oh you
didn't you wasn't able to do anything
with your life so you just so you just
had a kid.
>> Okay. I I see that was your only
purpose. Huh.
>> And and you know there's a very if you
want to read one book honestly really
good on this. Yeah. It's a book by James
Tulie. It's called The Miseducation of
Women
>> and he breaks it down. And one of the
things that he mentions is honestly I
really recommend this book. I mean it's
a fantastic it's an excellent book. One
of the things that he mentions in in the
book is what he refers to as domestic
drudgery. Okay, which the feminist
movement made it like mopping the floor
is a form of abuse. if she's cleaning
the house or something, if she's
cleaning making a meal for the So these
ideas started to be promulgated in the
1960s by secondary feminists. But now
they have been debunked and they've
shown that it's not the case that women
as we've just shown, right? Uh feel more
entrapped and feel less satisfied by
doing these things. And in fact, there's
good evidence to show the opposite.
>> You know, uh Candace um Owens.
>> Yeah, that's right. Her name is Candace
Owens. At the end of this,
>> she says something which I found quite
profound. It's very simple but very
powerful.
>> She has a book obviously called um Make
Him a Sandwich.
>> She's got a book like this.
>> I think she has a book that's called
Make Him a Sandwich.
>> She got a book like this. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> She's got a book called I believe it's a
book anyway, but they they mention
>> Good one.
>> I don't know. I didn't read. I just ate
a sandwich.
>> So, at the end she says, "I think we can
all agree like her and the 20 feminists
that she was with, she said, I think we
can all agree that a sandwich is a good
thing. The question is just who makes
it.
>> And I think that was quite profound.
Like the whole problem is not about the
sandwich. It's just about oh who does
it?
>> Well, and if it's a woman that's doing
certain things, it's demoting her like
you said.
>> Yeah.
>> Like
>> but you know it's mad. It's like if she
was working as a chef and it's her own
career, there's no demotion there. If
she's working as a even as a waitress,
bro. Like
>> and she might be getting peanuts.
>> Sorry to say how many
>> and getting treated worse.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And getting treated worse.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. Um, is there
another thing that we should be wor One
one more? I think there's one more,
right?
>> One more uh thing to to react to.
>> It just shows you that there is
fundamentally a hatred for tradition and
I think that hatred is being bred into
women.
>> Yeah, 100%. I think um a lot of the time
>> whenever you mention anything which is
stereotypically related to that of a
housewife,
>> it it gets so much negativity. Yeah,
>> like you mentioned something like like
her book, oh, can you make me a
sandwich? Why would you demote her? Why
don't you make your own sandwich? It
always turns into this. You know what I
mean? It turns into this whole
>> What's up?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm just
thinking, you know,
>> why don't you make your own sandwich?
Are you not capable of that yourself,
huh? Big big Mr. Big strong man. And it
>> turns into something else completely.
Like it's when are people going to
understand that the family unit is a
team? M
>> when you have a football team,
>> you might have Ronaldo scoring a goals.
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
>> He has his role,
>> the midfielder has his role, the
defender has his role, and the
goalkeeper has his role.
>> Some roles get more attention than other
roles. We're not saying that.
>> Striker.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Do you know what I
mean? Like that's that's all the all the
highlights are goals. Most of the
highlights are goals, right? When's the
last time you saw highlight what a
fantastic save?
>> Sometimes it does happen, but ratio
>> the ratio is way more. striker hitting
goals or midfielders hitting goals or
what have you.
>> They're still a team
>> and the striker without a goalkeeper,
he's going to he's going to lose the
match and the goalkeeper without the
striker is most likely going to lose the
match.
>> So, everyone has a part to play in the
puzzle. Everyone has a part to play in
the game, if you will, or in uh in that
unit, in the family unit.
>> We know
>> that to serve others
>> is is actually honorable.
>> To serve others is an honorable thing. M
>> and I don't understand why a woman
serving her children or serving her
husband
>> is looked down upon.
>> You see what I mean?
>> Yeah. Exactly. It's a good point, bro.
>> Because if once again, if you put that
same behavior in another context where
you're giving her a contract and a and a
white man's doing it acceptable,
>> it becomes accept if the white man's
doing if the white man's doing it in a
restaurant or in in some kind of
airplane where she's an air hostess or
or something like that.
>> It's absolutely fine. She's getting
paid. She's it's his job. It's a career.
>> You bring this even if you give that
let's say like for like you get the same
money as the
>> this
>> but you do it in this context.
>> Instead of doing it to 30 different
people you're just doing it to one.
>> It becomes unacceptable.
And the reason is not because of the
money. It's not because of the work. The
reason is simply because it's this man
here who she don't rate.
>> And I think it comes back it comes back
to this man is clipping her wings. It's
because of this man that she's unable to
chase her goals and chase her passions
and chase her dreams and chase her
career. It's because of him.
>> He's the problem. And then all of this
>> uh resentment,
>> self frustration gets directed to hatred
to this one individual. It becomes a lot
easier to point a to to blame a problem
on a person.
>> It's so much easier to blame your own
personal problems on anyone but
yourself.
>> That's the easy way out.
>> It's the right-wing approach.
It's like the far right, you know, the
immigration.
>> Taking our jobs, mate.
>> Take taking our jobs.
>> Yeah, that's what they're saying. This
is resentful disgruntled housewife.
>> She's taking our jobs. It's essentially
the same thing, isn't it?
>> If you think about it. Anyway, I think
it was an interesting um performance by
Candace. It wasn't highlighted before.
It was interesting to see someone
outside the community, but someone who
represents Christian values, you know,
and traditional values and who's
respected by a Muslim community taking
on these feminists and and being sober
in her approach and being able to
tactfully deal with the matters.
>> Um, I think it was good to see a woman
doing it. I know it sounds cliche to say
that but to be honest it is good to see
women doing this kind of thing because
as much as we can speak here and make
cogent and coherent points which we have
made throughout I'm sure the listeners
will agree it's sometimes more
psychologically comforting for women to
hear it from other women or men to hear
things from other men sometimes it is
like that doesn't mean it's a condition
though uh and having said that um you're
going to start up your YouTube page soon
aren't you?
>> Yep. And when you do, I think all these
people going to want to come and see
what you've um if they if they like my
style, then
if you don't, then it's all good, man.
>> It's all good. We'll make him make him a
sandwich. And and with that, we will
conclude with salamlay.
>> Hey, you are you wasting your time on
social media? Again, your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid, a da center.
Establishing a masid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahawel will give you even more.